It's 1928 and a Petri dish
left next to an open window
is about to revolutionise
modern medicine.
Scottish scientist
Alexander Fleming
finds that something in the
mould growing in the dish
is killing off bacteria.
It's penicillin, the
first antibiotic.
This wonder drug, and
other antibiotics,
will go on to treat
the untreatable,
saving millions of lives.
It's 2050.
The cupboard is bare.
Antibiotics were our
precious resource.
We needed to use them.
Of course we did.
But we weren't prudent.
Because each time we
used them, misused them,
and overused them, we
gave the bacteria a chance
to evolve, to become resistant.
And without global
leadership scientists
have been unable to bring
new antibiotics to market.
Now, even cuts have
fatal consequences.
Has the clock
really been ticking
towards a
post-antibiotic future,
where drug-resistant infections
kill 10m people a year?
Where chemotherapy is unsafe?
Where simple surgeries
are too risky to perform?
Where the world's biggest
child-killer, pneumonia,
is now unstoppable?
Is this just a projection?
2020.
Climate change is headline news.
Forests burn.
Scientists predict
rising sea levels.
There is a sense that time
for action is running out.
And then comes Covid.
It's a fast-moving pandemic.
A million dead and counting.
But the world
mobilises with urgency.
Individuals, doctors,
scientists, yes, governments
and policymakers, too.
The unthinkable
becomes the norm.
Cities, countries
under lockdown.
Economies radically reshaped.
Vaccines developed
in record time.
And against this
backdrop, a chance
to change the narrative on
that other looming global
catastrophe, the
one we already know
about - antibiotic resistance.
Because everyone sees
now, we can mobilise.
We can take individual and
collective responsibility,
and we must be prepared.
It's 1945.
The Allied victory.
That was a collective
effort, too.
During World War Two penicillin
has been mass produced,
used to treat soldiers'
septic wounds.
Hailed as a victory
of science over death.
But as he collects
his Nobel Prize,
Fleming is already
issuing a warning.
Misusing antibiotics
can hasten the evolution
of drug-resistant
bacteria and render them
useless for future generations.
Here's how it works with E
coli in a giant Petri dish.
The E coli bacteria hits a
line of antibiotic and pause,
until a random mutation
enables the bacteria
to overcome the drug.
At each line, the antibiotic
is 10 times more concentrated,
but there are also
more mutations.
It's evolution by
natural selection,
only very, very fast.
We live in a Petri dish, too.
The bacteria are a
part of our ecosystem
- around us, within us.
Trillions upon trillions,
helpful as well as harmful.
And resistance is
natural, to be expected.
But by increased misuse we
only encouraged the mutations.
We overprescribed.
Of course we did.
Medicine is not
an exact science.
Diagnosis is difficult, and
people expect to be cured.
In some parts of the world
antibiotics don't even
need a prescription at all.
They're over the counter or
at the back of the drawer.
But against viral coughs,
colds, and sore throats,
they're useless -
worse than useless.
We give them to our
farm animals, too.
We want to prevent infection.
We want to plump our food.
We want cheap meat.
It's the 1980s.
This is the start of
the discovery void.
For more than 30 years no
new classes of antibiotics
will be launched.
Why?
Follow the money,
and it runs out.
Big Pharma has no incentive
to invest in the development
of antibiotics.
There's no profit.
It's expensive, time consuming,
and complex, and single use.
While antidepressants
and heart drugs - they
make money on repeat
Meanwhile, controls
designed to limit
the inappropriate use
of antibiotics also limit
financial incentives
for making them.
It's 2020, the here and now,
and we have some of the answers.
Preventing infections with
better hygiene and vaccines.
We can repackage
existing antibiotics
to make them resistance-proof.
Or use phage therapy to attack
the bacteria with viruses.
And in the future AI could lead
to more accurate diagnoses.
Surely new antibiotics must
be part of the answer, too.
Funding agreements can
give the bigger companies
the financial incentive.
Partnerships can give smaller
companies access to resources.
And what about de-linking
volume from profit?
Concentrating not on the number
of pills but their value.
Paying companies not for how
much antibiotic they provide,
but its potential worth
to the health system.
Something like a subscription.
Something like insurance.
The building is catching fire.
The edifice is crumbling.
The cupboard is running bare.
Already, antibiotic resistance
is killing 700,000 people
a year.
In some ways Covid has
made the problem worse.
Fears about secondary
infections mean
large quantities
of antibiotics have
been prescribed to patients.
But Covid could help
make things better, too.
If it motivates us, if
the world mobilises -
individuals, doctors,
scientists, yes, governments
and policy makers, too.
The solutions are scientific,
but they're also economic,
and they're societal.
It's a collective effort.
It's not a projection.
It's not a sort of an
imaginary projection
that it's going to get worse.
We know that's going to happen.
And because we know that
it's going to happen,
we actually also know
how we can slow it down.
You realise that actually all
those things that you prepare
for - it's so that you've got
it there when you need it.
Everyone has their part to play.
The point is we do
have the opportunity
to do something about it.